[Music]
yesterday the best chess players in the
world who are back for the 2018 edition
of the Sinquefield cup kids and fans
from all over the country and all over
the world came to see their favorite
players and get that once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity to get a special autograph
later it was time for the opening
ceremony everyone excited to get the
event started the board stopped on the
Grantchester and all the importance of
the players trying to get coveted for
spots to London
the super wild card world champion
magnus carlsen was there in fine form as
was his challenger Fabiano Caruana and
both of them got into it the
trash-talking starting early I think a
victory here means a lot but I don't
know if it has any direct correlation to
the match I mean I think that once we
get to London will probably be
forgetting all the past results and just
be focusing on the match itself but a
win in any top tournament especially
here in st. Louis would mean a lot to me
Magnus I like to address the same
question to you there's a victory here
mean anything as far as London is
concerned
well not for me but I think Fabi needs
to win the tournament too to get to
longer being being the Grand chess to
refine a lot to watch Apogee
[Applause]
your thoughts on that Fabiano your need
you need to win the event well I think
the last few months I have generally won
tournaments in which Magnus is playing
in so III meant I didn't mean to trash
talk I meant to just state something
factual
[Music]